[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing a theory of mine involving
queerness quirrell voldemort and none
other than gilderoy lockhart more
specifically i'm going to be explaining
to you guys how lockhart ruined
quirrell's life
now the first thing you may be wondering
is what is the relevance of quirrell and
lockhart's relationship do we ever even
see them interact do they even appear in
the same book or film well the answer to
that is of course no but this particular
theory scratches quite a bit more
beneath the surface the only loose
connection in canon that connects these
two gentlemen is that they both at one
stage assume the role of defense against
the dark arts professor at hogwarts
quirrell was the defense against the
dark arts professor in harry's first
year in the philosopher's stone and
lockhart was defense against the dark
arts professor in harry's second year in
the chamber of secrets by the time
lockhart rolls around in the second film
quirrell is no more defeated at the
hands of harry potter so again how are
these two characters related in any way
well my theory is that these men
actually met each other at one stage in
the past one year before harry started
at hogwarts in the year 1990 to begin to
gain an understanding of my theory here
we need to look at a few aspects of the
backstories of these two gentlemen so
that i can better rationalize how many
crossed paths in the harry potter
timeline let's start with quirrell
guerina squirrel was an english half
blood wizard born sometime in the 1960s
when a years of age began attending
hogwarts at which point he was sorted
into ravenclaw house quirrell was a
highly unusual and delicate but talented
student and was teased profusely at
school making the anxious quarrel even
more anxious his feelings of inadequacy
led to him taking a particular interest
in the dark arts a highly complicated
and dangerous field of magic that could
perhaps garner queer all the attention
and respect that he was longed for for
the duration of his studies he showed a
particular affinity for the dark arts
and he ended up graduating from hogwarts
with impressive grades across the board
it wasn't very long after he himself had
graduated that he was able to secure a
job as muggle studies professor at
hogwarts unfortunately the bullying that
quirrell endured in childhood would have
a profound effect on the actions that he
would take as a grown man the brief
intro above is intended to give you a
glimpse of the type of person that
quirrell was a sort of character
analysis revealing him to be a neurotic
man that sought recognition this is an
important aspect of the theory now
lockhart just like quirrell gilderoy
lockhart was a half-blood wizard born in
the 1960s 1964 to be exact lockhart had
two sisters but he ended up being the
only one that was magical making him
unofficially his mother's favorite child
lockhart was a clever good-looking boy
and when he realized quite early on that
he was magical it only went to his head
and inflated his already massive ego in
1975 lockhart first stepped foot into
the halls of hogwarts however he was met
with a certain degree of disappointment
as here he was just another magical
child not a special unique magical child
like he was in the muggle world from the
moment he began his studies he no longer
stood out and despite his best efforts
merely possessed slightly above average
magical abilities
nothing special i should also mention
here that lockhart was just like
quirrell sorted into ravenclaw house
we know that later in life lockhart
becomes a massive fraud blatantly lying
and taking credit for the work of others
in order to fuel his own ego and
reputation but what you may not have
known is that this pattern of behavior
began very early on in his childhood
though his backstory differed from
quarrels there are certainly a lot of
parallels here and one thing they both
had in common was that they felt
inadequate now that we've established
their individual stories according to
canon here's how i've theorized that
their stories are interconnected and how
lockhart inadvertently ruined quirrell's
life
in 1990 after teaching for several years
as the mughal studies professor at
hogwarts quirrell became shall we say
fed up this led to him taking a
year-long sabbatical in order to gain
first-hand experience in the field
however coral's real objective was to
find lord voldemort fueled by his
intense need to be recognized and
acknowledged quirrell set off with the
belief that if he was the one to find
voldemort he would be praised by all of
the wizarding world and find voldemort
he did
however things didn't go exactly
according to plan as he was easily
manipulated and controlled by voldemort
this is what led to his eventual
possession by the dark lord voldemort
recounts just how easy quirrell was to
manipulate a wizard young foolish and
gullible wandered across my path in the
forest i had made my home oh he seemed
the very chance i'd been dreaming of for
he was a teacher at dumbledore school he
was easy to bend my will he brought me
back to this country and after a while i
took possession of his body to supervise
him closely as he carried out my orders
now when it comes to strength of
character quirrell was quite weak
however he did possess above average
magical ability and he was also
extremely intelligent so it's hard to
imagine how an extremely weakened
voldemort was able to bend quirrell to
his will quite so easily mentor lockhart
after lockhart graduated from hogwarts
he began travelling the world in search
of a way to fill his void of inadequacy
lockhart wanted to be a man of legend
this eventually led to his illustrious
career as an author where he informed
the wizarding world of his tales of
heroism he tamed dragons and captured
dark wizards but the catch was that he
was the only one ever there to witness
it through his stories he became famous
and he left a genuinely positive
impression on most of the wizarding
population however we of course know
that there is quite a sinister component
to lockhart's character you see lockhart
was a memory charm master and this was
one of the reasons that he had been able
to falsify his well existence lockhart
wasn't a troll conqueror dragon tamer he
was a phony and all he did when he
traveled around the world was hear the
stories of genuinely accomplished
wizards wipe their memories then claim
the accomplishment as his own i think
that when quirrell traveled to albania
in 1990 lockhart was there at that very
same moment quirrell was there to find
voldemort and lockhart was there to find
an unsuspecting wizard to steal an
accomplishment from here's how i think
it played out quirrell and lockhart bump
into each other in the forest of albania
provided they were both ravenclaw
students and just a few years apart at
hogwarts they were savvy to each other's
existence they greet and exchange
formalities and it's at this stage that
quirrell reveals to lockhart that he's
tracked down voldemort informing him
that he's in the same forest where
they're having that very discussion at
that stage no one knew much about
voldemort's whereabouts so when lockhart
heard from quirrell that voldemort was
nearby he saw dollar signs lockhart who
wanted to be a man of legend immediately
envisioned himself from the front cover
of the daily prophet gilderoy lockhart
the man who found lord voldemort this
then prompted lockhart a man of dubious
character to wipe the memory of his old
schoolmate lockhart wouldn't have wanted
to have risked quirrell finding
voldemort and getting away so in order
to ensure that he was the only possible
person to be credited with finding the
dark lord he immediately leveraged one
of his famous memory charms
unfortunately however lockhart used a
little too much mustard when casting the
spell on quirrell overdoing it just a
tad this meant that quirrell after being
struck with lockhart's spell was left in
a very disorientated impressionable
state with the d done lockhart left
quirrell to his own devices and it was
just after this happened that voldemort
came upon quirrell easier to manipulate
than ever given that lockhart was a
coward and would have never actually
faced voldemort himself it's unlikely
that he would have actually searched for
him he would have just returned to
england and claimed that he had engaged
with voldemort but just before heading
home lockhart saw corel's interaction
with voldemort from afar and fearing
that he would be held responsible for
quirrell's uncertain fate and fearing
that voldemort may target him made the
decision that he would never disclose
any information about that one curious
trip to albania what do you guys think
of this theory did i miss something let
me know in the comment section below
until next time remember i didn't get
rid of the abandoned banshee by smiling
at her
[Music]
you